hey how's it goin braces Wow so here we
are this a new level that we need to
complete the pros can we do it probably
no and goddamn I'm already struggling
are you kidding me you know what oh god
I'm dead I'm dead now okay go to the
plant planty planty planty blue I love
you bloody you son of a cup I swear to
God I will I will [ __ ] your plan oh my
god that was that was the worst one I
ever had in my life
what if we launched ourselves unto one
of the leaves there seems to be some
wind yes
maybe we can sail the leaf to victory I
know a thing or two about sailing I
think you may think I'm stupid you may
think I'm crazy and you're absolutely
right ah whoa I got it I got it oh that
was that was a piece of cake I mean a
piece of toast I'm a piece of toast
humping a plant my life is made it does
not get any better than this
alright we're gonna have to make a jump
for it here but oh no problem
okay we're just gonna have to launch
like we always stop hunting okay
skateboard I choose You Pikachu Pikachu
[ __ ] you funky
yes we did it Wow skate skate skate
skate herb read see see you later bred
he wasn't good enough uh-huh okay we
can't climb the car oh god oh god no no
no what is the toes doing out there
maybe if the toes is on top of a garbage
bin you should not eat it from the front
maybe I should just kill myself climb
the plants they said you're crazy I said
then we climb the plant where the [ __ ]
am I going outside ah ah ah are you
white or brown you ain't live
you ain't live if you ain't fought like
a toast toast for toast
this is for my toasty bros but don't die
don't die you're so close you're surfers
Yeah right what is this a toolbox ah
Barbra Streisand [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah maybe here maybe this is it could
it be that easy
am I being toasted no I'm just dipping
myself and [ __ ] just just just [ __ ]
touch it just [ __ ] touch it with you
I swear to God
thank you ah ah too fat I can't do it
puts see I'm gonna die now you're just
laughing argh you see great okay
you know what I see some [ __ ] on top of
that [ __ ] maybe we need to [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] yes got it don't stop believin
you're a bread and wonderful able know
what up ah we did it we did it
spider loaf spider love just whatever a
spider loaf oh god get the [ __ ] up get
get get the [ __ ] away from me
this is like the new Mission Impossible
movie right here don't stop believin bad
Ariel you're a bread and [ __ ] autistic
real there's a grill there's a grill
there's a grout our out if there's grill
there is hope I repeat if there's grill
ah ah ah
I'm not your k putz shut up red one two
oh oh oh it's amazing
thank the Swedish Viking Lords Oh
all right we can do another leap of
faith I feel it Oh amazing that is that
working a system is this some kind of
sick joke why aren't we breading what
kind of barbecue piece of [ __ ] is this
you best be joking with me right now I'm
not I'm not in the mood red yeah that
makes sense we might as well just kill
ourselves we're gonna do this we gotta
do it in one try look at my ass baby
look yeah they yes Nate Nate Nate Nate
are you [ __ ] my pants are [ __ ]
ah-ah-ah-ah no I did not add not I did
not oh yes
lift lift the [ __ ] is wrong with you
no no no no dad it's not a big deal oh
we need it again
we made again brah
what grab it what are you doing oh I
don't know I did that but I'm so happy
just give me a reason give me a reason
just give me a reason
Savion see me on you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh right so I need to
pull Venus inside okay here we go oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh
toast toast my anus oh god I'm getting
really burned ah sweet euphoria ha we
did a breast oh I was so easy all right
gross if you are a ho leave a like I
mean no wait uh yes brofist on the
brofist what is happening what is
happening I don't like this I think I
turned it on aah Oh God contamination
wait I'm being toasted right now a big
toasted Wow